bonjour rocco contento merci de répondre
à nos questions en direct sur arte
france que le couvre-feu va donc
mobilisé près de douze mille policiers
et gendarmes sur le gouvernement
dans quel état d'esprit sont vos
collègues vis-à-vis de ce nouveau
dispositif
il a écouté nos collègues sont très en
colère puisque nous sommes une nouvelle
fois mis à contribution pour la bonne
application du couvre feu
je vous rappelle que nous avons été mis
à contribution pour faire appliquer le
confinement
ensuite pour accompagner le
déconfinement et là nous avons mission
de faire respecter le couvre-feu
je rappelle que ce n'est pas notre coeur
de métier notre coeur de métier c'est
lutter contre la petite grande et
moyenne délinquance
et pendant que nous veillerons à au
contrôle des attestations c'est du temps
que nous ne prendrons pas partis pour
lutter contre cette délinquance ne
faudra pas s'étonner que les
statistiques de délinquance remonte en
l'occurrence le syndicat de police
alliance affirme je cite que dans les
quartiers dits sensibles ce sera très
compliqué de faire respecter un
couvre-feu après herblay après champigny
après les récentes actions contre les
forces de l'ordre
comment est-ce que vos collègues peuvent
intervenir dans ces quartiers pour faire
respecter le couvre-feu
concrètement oui effectivement ça va
être très compliqué dans les zones
sensibles dans certaines zones sensibles
notamment de banlieue
par exemple confinement n'a pas du tout
été respectée malgré tout les collègues
ou pénétrer ces sites là pour faire
appliquer le confinement et jeu nous
avons eu affaire à 379 incident entre
mars et mai 2020 pendant la table de
confinement avec 43 blessés parmi les
forces de l'ordre
je voudrais ajouter quelque chose
d'important ou l'admission à faire nous
sommes des policiers républicains ou
services de l'état nous allons
l'effectuer mais c'est plutôt là le
modus operandi ce qui ne nous plaît pas
il faut savoir que ce sont donc les
policiers de nuit qui vont faire
appliquer le couvre-feu la ressource la
nuit est beaucoup moins importante que
le jour c'est pour cela que les
autorités de la préfecture de police ou
d'autorité décalé des collègues qui
travaillent de jour la nuit ce qui veut
dire que dès ce soir des collègues
étaient censés travailler le jour vont
se retrouver à travailler de 22h à 6h du
matin ce qui n'est pas acceptable
puisque ces personnes là mes collègues
ont une vie sociale familiale et
personnelle est qu'ils doivent vraiment
s'organiser en très peu de temps donc ça
nous allons pousser un coup de colère en
direction de la préfecture mais aussi du
ministre de l'intérieur
ça veut dire qu'il ya un sous effectif
c'est ce que vous dénoncez bassillac en
fait mathématiquement vous avez beaucoup
moins d'effectifs la nuit que le jour
est comme entre guillemets le
gouvernement veut mettre le paquet la
ressource de jours et mobiliser la lui
nous effectuons notre mission les
premiers temps avec discernement il
s'agit pas non plus de véritable
événement à votre ministre de tutelle le
ministre de l'intérieur gérald darmanin
eh bien vous avez à paris notamment une
police municipale même si elle n'est pas
gravé dans le marbre qui existe avec
plusieurs milliers d'agents ci plutôt
aussi leur travail il faut les mettre à
contribution pour faire appliquer les
règles du couvre feu nous en ce qui nous
concerne nous avons fort à faire entre
lutter contre la délinquance et trafic
de stupéfiants et aussi je vous rappelle
le terrorisme qui est encore présent
malheureusement on en a encore été
témoin hier soir quelle conséquence va
avoir ce couvre feu sur les forces de
l'ordre
en comparaison avec le confinement par
exemple aidé de les conséquences
de quelle nature préciser s'il ne sait
pas ce qu'il peut y avoir des
conséquences d'ordre psychologique par
exemple des conséquences vous parliez
tout à l'heure de la vie de famille
notamment oui oui complètement
c'est perturbant pour mes collègues
surtout les collègues de nuit encore
qu'ils ont lancée que de nuit ça va pas
changer grand chose pour eux mais les
collègues qui sont menées à contribution
la nuit alors que habituellement ils
travaillent le jour ça va être compliqué
puisque ils vont devoir dormir le jour
alors qu'ils sont habitués à dormir la
nuit se restaurer des heures différentes
tout ça c'est un panier de la sensation
avec des primes de nuit est non alors le
statut travailleurs de lui cet autre
chose le ministre a fait une annonce
mais les collègues de jour qui
travaillent la nuit ne bénéficieront pas
du statut travailleurs de nuit parce que
je vous rappelle qu'il faut effectuer un
certain nombre d'heures dans l'année
pour bénéficier de ce statut
donc si vous voulez ça râle dans l'âme
et dans la maison police
on fera quand même la mission parce que
nous sommes des policiers républicains
mais voilà il faut pas nous en demander
trop non plus puisque le policier où est
mis à contribution en ce moment et
depuis un certain temps pour tout
n'importe quoi merci rocco contento
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes secrétaire
départemental paris d'unité sgp police